oh my God he's an amazing dad he's an
amazing dad he brings tears to my eyes
Jennifer Lopez tearing up over hubby and
proud dad Ben Affleck he is honestly the
best dad I've ever seen the triple
threat stopped by The View on Thursday
the Hot Topic the upcoming one-year
anniversary since Jen and Ben tied the
knot in Sin City
somebody's getting married we're super
happy
um what can I tell you how about telling
the talk show panel what makes Affleck a
super dad oh my God he's an amazing dad
he's an amazing dad he can bring steers
to my eyes it's just he is honestly the
best dad I've ever seen present loving
dad who cares and shows up every single
day and that's who he is we're gonna
give it away but it has a very good
ending no he teaches me about how to
kind of interact with the kids sometimes
he's just so in tune and he's he's such
a brilliant guy anyway like he's so
learned in so many things and and you
could just tell like when he had his
kids he must have read every book and
everything that you could possibly learn
about children and and he applies it
yeah like how he applied his coaching
skills to his son's baseball team if the
kids are running the right direction
around the bases then I've succeeded as
a coach that's about the extent of my
coaching ability of course Ben shares
three kids with ex-wife Jennifer Garner
Violet Seraphina and Samuel my areas of
expertise is the kids it's not homework
plus he's a stepdad to JLo and
ex-husband Marc Anthony's 15 year old
twins Max and Emmy they're so big and so
amazing and happy so who's the tougher
parent at home I feel like right now I'm
in the moment of the mother
um and I remember this about my mom it's
funny about Mother's Day and appreciate
appreciation for your own mom I remember
my mom saying to me I'm always the bad
guy I'm always the bad guy I got a
discipline you I gotta do this I gotta
do that yep that's her mom Lupe in the
audience watching Jen break down how
parentings come full circle but there
was a time in the I think it's in those
teenage years and you're just like oh
as the fans know wherever J-Lo goes Lupe
flows the whole conversation especially
says you have to see this movie She's
incredible crashing Her Today Show
interview on Wednesday and then when you
talked about Ben what did you tell me
she is my mom she knew you'd always knew
that you would always get back together
because I prayed for 20 years
okay as Jennifer said let's keep going
over here
well seems everyone Lupe included is
here for benefit 2.0 it's just a dream
come true
foreign